let's pick up next on our caller from
the four one five area code who's
calling today from four one five hey
David how are you this morning this is
Joseph hey Joseph what's up hey so I was
assumed she was talking about paths
forward for the Democratic Party and I
was kind of wondering what you think
what your thought would be of Sanders
basically trying to come to an agreement
with Biden to get some of his agenda
point as agenda points into the
Democratic Party's on the idea that he
would drop out but the idea that with
that the Senators dropping out of the
race you can get basically Bloomberg
money to push money into all the
different states get some agenda point
and get maybe some sort of unity I hate
using unity yeah between the left and
the more moderate republic more moderate
Democrat so listen you're thinking
pragmatically and I like it the idea
would be it increasingly looks like
Bernie Sanders is not going to be able
to catch Joe Biden why do I say that I
know people will be furious well when
you look at the momentum Joe Biden has
and you look at the outstanding states
still to vote like Florida where Biden
is doing very well there there is not a
clear path for Bernie Sanders to
overtake Joe Biden but you've got it
you've got to do it let's imagine that
we have the March 10th votes happen and
Biden's lead gets even bigger okay
Bernie can just fight it out until the
convention that's one possibility and I
think a lot of Bernie supporters would
say that's exactly what he should do
fight it to the end or knowing that
Michael Bloomberg has now endorsed Joe
Biden we don't have to like Michael
Bloomberg but we can still recognize
that is hundreds of millions poured into
the race could help to defeat Donald
Trump Bernie says listen I will say
Joba I will come out and end my campaign
and say Joe Biden is the way forward
because Joe has agreed to adopt whatever
right my medicare-for-all plan my free
college plan whatever I actually think
that it's a very good idea because to
talk about it in exactly the clearest
possible terms it's so insanely unlikely
that that stuff would get through the
Senate that Biden could
say it and there's very little risk
there's very little risk to say it and
it could ensure that not that many
Bernie supporters end up staying home or
voting for Trump then you combine that
with Bloomberg's money and you set
yourself up to defeat Donald Trump so I
think you're thinking about this in a
sort of dispassionate pragmatic way a
lot of people in my audience don't like
that type of thinking but I think that
there is a lot to that and there would
be very little risk to Joe Biden because
if Bernie does that it's just it's over
Biden's the nominee then it's just a
matter of fighting Trump yeah exactly
the idea is that if you can get
Bloomberg's up to 100 million dollars
per state to move all the state races in
the Democratic path right you end the
fight now within a Democratic Party
because if this goes to the convention
do you really think that the left wing
of the of the Bernie bros are gonna vote
for basically by Biden go to the polls
it'll be self-destructive if after this
particularly when remember listen before
the idea was Bernie will have a
plurality but not a majority and they'll
hand it to bide in one way or the other
that is not likely to be the situation
the likely situation now is Biden has a
plurality possibly a large plurality
maybe even a majority although it's not
super likely that's very different and
having a fraught convention with that is
the scenario I don't see that the
political benefit of doing yeah that's
the issue I see also I think if you go
to the full all the way to the
convention and a hard-fought bernie side
versus Biden side fight I don't see it I
just see so many people on the left
being in in a civil war mode I think
would be a freaking disaster I think you
have you have many people on the Left is
sitting out well every candidate no
matter who runs there will be
abandonment meaning someone who decides
to vote for the other side because they
don't like the candidate there will be
some stay home percentage that that
applies to every single candidate but I
think here we have a very specific
situation where there is a movement of
Bernie supporters who if Joe but if
Bernie were to say Joe has agreed to
by his platform to include these three
things of mine right medicare-for-all
being the most important one and again I
know Biden doesn't want it I don't think
we're gonna get it underway right like
just sit just say you're done the thing
is that you don't even have to say
Medicare for all you can say basically
give these enhancements to the ACA that
gets it past they'll be more moderates
and if they can sell it to the left
saying here are the ways we're going to
change the ACA yeah man-up verbage we'll
just change it because I would I see and
you're talking about it's like you had a
2016 and on the Republican side you had
out this whole group of voters who were
the never Trump errs well they've all
come home now right they were they were
amazing millions of Republicans who
refuse to vote Trump in 2016 in 2020 if
this gets to a second ballot or even to
a first ballot it goes to the full
convention yeah I see millions on the
left is sitting it out and having what
you saw in 2016 happy to 2020 except
rather than that basically allow the
left sitting out I'm sorry the right
sitting out in 2016 I see a lot of the
left sitting out in 2020 we'll listen I
understand why you're saying it I hope
it doesn't happen and your your
strategic idea is well taken by me
although it's sick that we're we're
trying to figure out how to defeat Trump
by getting the centrist candidate to say
he'll do some of the progressive things
Bernie wants to do while taking money
from a billionaire oligarch like it's
sick that this is how we're trying to
figure out how to be Trump right that's
the depressing thing but think about it
you don't put in like 1% of his wealth
to save 5% is wealth from the wealth tax
yep you know I don't even think the
wealth tax was going to happen but
that's a different that's a different
debate but I understand what you're
saying yeah anyway all right what I just
want to talk about and I really want to
thank you David
thank you also understand I'm not she
very conservative oh okay but I think
that if there's any sane way to have
this happen I think that they need to
kind of make some really sharp decisions
on
forward and pull both of the dem party
sides together yep I totally agree and
and again if you don't if you don't care
about that if you'd rather if it's not
going to be Bernie if you'd rather it be
Trump then it'll be Trump that's that's
the reality all right thank you my
friend appreciate the phone call great
to hear from you